thank you to Shopify and expressvpn for
sponsoring this video more on them after
the
reaction how's it going citizens of the
reject Nation we are here for another
solo cinematic sojourn catching up on a
9s classic uh that I have heard a lot
about over time I remember seeing the
picture of Brad Pit in the calendar
section of the newspaper being very
compelling by that image uh and since
then the Mystique has only Built I can
only imagine what the actual experience
of watching the movie will be like at
this point but uh we're going to break
that illusion in just a moment it's time
for David Fincher's fight club based on
the novel by Chuck Panic
po however you say that leave a like for
cinematic adaptations of novels leave a
like for uh what I am sure is going to
be a completely inspiring and uh
aspirational motion picture be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
to get notified every time one of these
movie reactions comes your way or could
come your way um and as always big
thanks to prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights it is tough work
and if you would like to see everything
that doesn't make these reaction
highlight reels you want to get the full
fight club experience alongside me come
on over to patreon.com theal rejects
where you can sync up with your own copy
we also got a ton of other shows and
movies over there with highlights and
watch alongs included without further
ado my friends get yourself some reject
merch I psyched you out haha uh yeah
reation shop.com if you want to support
the channel and rock a little swag in
the process show your reject Nation
Pride come on over there it's a great
way it's our one of our favorite ways to
support the channel and uh now without
further Ado uh let's put up our Dukes
cuz it's time for Fight
Club people are always asking me if I
know Tyler Duran 3 minutes uh this is it
whoa hey would you like to say a few
words to Mark the
occasion with a barrel between your
teeth you speak only in
vows we have front row seats for this
theater of mass destruction oh my whoa
Project Mayhem wrapped the foundation
Columns of a dozen buildings with
blasting gel damn primary charges will
blow base charges and a few square
blocks will be reduced to smoldering
Rubble I know this because Tyler knows
this okay
I realized that all of this the gun the
bombs the revolution has got something
to do with a girl named Mara singer of
course it's always hello I'm Bob Bob had
bitched
what this was a support group for men
with testicular cancer the big moosey
slobbering all over me that was Bob
we're still men we're still men between
those huge sweating that hung enormous
the way you'd think of gods as you cry
now you cry now please clap let me start
earlier for 6 months I couldn't sleep I
couldn't sleep I couldn't sleep hey
what's up product placement everything's
far away everything's a copy of a copy
oh a copy of a copy of going to need you
out of town a little more this week we
got some red flags to cover call me from
the road if there's any snacks he was
full of pet must have had his grande
latte
enema sure I want to see that scene
grande latte enema would be on like the
IDI y Starbucks menu if I saw something
clever like a little coffee table in the
shape of a yinyang I had to have it sure
the clip personal office unit the hover
TR home exer bike even the rampa wire
lamps of environmentally friendly
unbleached paper W this is reminding me
of like a a maled American Psycho you
can't die from insomnia what about
narcolepsy I KN off I wake up in strange
places I have no idea how I got there
you need to lighten up you want my
opinion you ought to lighten
up I'm in pain you want to see pain
swing by First Methodist Tuesday nights
see the guys with testicular cancer oh
my that's pain whoa God these flashes
good at embodying this yeah
Insomniac perspective and like with his
narration being so sort of like detached
in lacad isical almost she had her first
child last week uh with her new husband
okay I'm I'm glad for
her
she oh dude it's time for the one-on
ones so let's all of us here follow
Thomas's good example and really open
ourselves up oh my waa I want to go back
and pause for those but I don't want to
mess up the stream his eyes already
shrink wrapped in tears oh oh my
goodness gracious those awkward little
steps must have given him some kind of
prosthetic Bob had been a champion
bodybuilder you know that chest
expansion program you see on late night
TV that was his idea Wow we must
increase our bust using steroids habol
and whst all oh they use that bra hores
for Christ sakes God in the high
register in his voice you can cry oh boy
oh my God how many hundreds of times did
they do these
takes and then something happened
I let go really good oh my you had a
breakthrough I found Freedom losing all
hope was Freedom
whoa like the Jesus cloth oh my God and
a roar Shack and you've got the choir
going like it's on some kind of old
cassette tape jeez babies don't sleep
this well I became addicted what you
just crash in every support group
possible who my
God people always assume the worst they
cried harder then I cried harder wa
unlock your emotions man vulnerability
is the key now keep this going remember
to breathe and step forward through the
back door of the room where does it lead
to your cave whoa from the matter Horn
Mountain you're going deeper into your
cave and you're going to find rert jesz
these names he's choosing
should be Mr poer
what
alen every evening I died and every
evening I was born again sure
resurrected Bob loved me because he
thought my testicles were removed too
this was my vacation this is like a
really messed up David Sedaris essay and
she whoa ruined everything everything
cancer
right jeez coming looking like a
Shinigami looking like ryuk right now
she was a
liar I had seen her at free and clear
parasites group Thursdays and again it
sees the day my tuberculosis Friday
night territorial about his clicks her
lie reflected my lie the the gift I felt
nothing wow I couldn't sleep yeah how
many thousands of takes did that smoke
shot
require is that Tyler in the flat like
kind of look like Brad Pit but obviously
the point is it's never long enough for
you to catch it now let's ready oursel
for guided meditation oh yes if I did
have a tumor I'd name it
[Music]
Mara slide slide fly Ed fly you're a
faker
you're not dying sorry in the Tibetan
philosophy syia Plath sense of the word
I know we're all we're all dying so
you're a tourist saw you saw you had
melanoma saw you had tuberculosis I saw
you had testicular cancer and now you're
gatekeeping practicing what telling me
off is it going as well as you hoped
rert rert I'll expose you go ahead I'll
expose you yeah what would you expect
dude why do you do it when people think
you're dying man they I really really
listen to you instead of just instead of
just waiting for their turn to speak
yeah ooh instead of just trying to yeah
solve your [__] and whisk you away look
you don't want to get into this it
becomes an addiction really oh my god
there should be a a a support group
addict Anonymous we're going to split up
the week okay you take lymphoma and
tuberculosis you take tuberculosis my
smoking going go over it all this is so
absurd I'll take the blood parasites but
I'm going to take the organic brain
Dimension you can't have the whole brain
you can't have the whole brain take the
first and third Sunday of the month deal
deal maybe we should exchange numbers
should we we might want to switch nights
oh my
goodness okay she's
always she's always like gracefully
gliding through the chaotic traffic you
wake up at seac who you wake up at
O'Hare Dallas Fort worth lose an hour
gain an hour check in for that flight
doesn't begin for another 2 hours sir oh
no if you wake up at a different time in
a different place could you wake up as a
different person there's your boy could
you wake up as that guy on a long enough
timeline the survival rate for everyone
drops to zerooo I was a recall
coordinator my job was to apply the
formula here's the INF win through the
windshield three points three points
should we initiate a recall the father
must have been huge you see where the
fats burned the SE wow very modern
art ghoulish take the number of vehicles
in the field and multiply the result by
the average out ofc Court settlement
C if x is less than the cost of a recall
we don't do one
wow which car company do you work for
yep my thoughts exactly every time the
plane banked too sharply on takeoff for
landing I prayed for a crash oh
what nightmare oh my God life insurance
pays off triple if you die on a business
trip what it does is that a somebody
fact check that and get in the comments
and feel you would be unable are
unwilling to perform the duties listed
on the safety card please ask a flight
attendant to reced you it's a lot of
responsibility an exodor procedure at
30,000 ft the illusion of safety oh man
there's so much illusion of safety in
our society today in a catastrophic
emergency you're taking giant Panic
breaths suddenly you become euphoric you
accept your fate woof emergency water
Landing 600 mph faces calm as Hindu
cows I mean they should draw an honest
version of the airline pamphlet what do
relevant why you can pretend like you're
interested no I want to hear man let's
Network I love networking I'm all about
networking I make and I sell
soap the
poster and this is how I met Tyler dton
Tyler Duran if you mixed equal parts of
gasoline and frozen orange juice
concentrate you can make Napal ah good
to know one can make all kinds of
explosives using simple household items
really if one were so
inclined I idolized this man immediately
how I came to live with Tyler is
Airlines have this policy about
vibrating
luggage really how many electric razors
and personal wands is that related to my
suitcase was vibrating nine times out of
10 it's an electric razor but there you
go every once in a
while you knew this was coming
Pete yep yep yep home was a condo on the
15th floor of a filing cabinet for
widows a place to be somebody the walls
were solid concrete a foot of concrete's
important when your next door neighbor
lets her hearing aid go and has to watch
game shows at full volume scat or when a
volcanic blast of debris that used to be
your furniture and personal effects
blows out of your floor to ceiling
windows and sails flaming into the night
damn this building looks familiar I
suppose these things happen
whoa Tyler come and blow up your place
you like NAB your info from the airline
while your bag goes out and like come
the police would later tell me that the
pilot light might have gone out letting
out just a little bit of gas that gas
could have slowly filled the condo
whoa there some CG in those shots for
[Music]
sure and the refrigerator's compressor
could have clicked on looks good but
it's interesting cuz you know we think
of we don't think of CG in movies like
this the same
way I can hear you breathing
paper Street soap if you asked me now I
couldn't tell you why I called
him man rip pay phones very cinematic so
much you can do a long lens and a
punching some numbers slamming it down
on the
[Music]
receiver exit The Matrix hello who's
this Brad Pitt's junk food contract in
full effect there was no answer I'm at a
pay for yeah star 69 do I never pick up
my
phone just chowing over there I had it
all I had my that was very decent a
wardrobe that was getting very
respectable oh man all your
stuff do you know what a de is yes it's
a blanket just a blanket why do guys
like you and I know what a de is it's a
it's a dick blanket murder crime poverty
these things don't concern me what
concerns me celebrity magazines
television with 500 channels some guy's
name on my underwear got to get the best
name on your underwear things you own
end up owning you oh he said it seen
that on a lot of infographics just find
a hotel just ask man three pictures of
beer and you still can't ask a kiss him
you fool you called me cuz you need a
place to stay oh hey hey no no no I
didn't should just ask a yeah stop
diddling the man can I stay at your
place
yeah I mean I would have trouble getting
to that point I want you do me a favor I
want you to hit me as hard as you can oh
here we go let me tell you a little bit
about Tyler Duran Tyler wasn't night
person oh hey there let's do this he had
one part-time job as a projectionist he
lived in blowout if you look for it you
can see these little dots come into the
upper right hand corner of the screen
yeah oh in the industry we call them
cigarette Burns yes he Clips the
projectors movie keeps right on going
and nobody in the audience has any
idea CU it affords him other interesting
opportunities thanks exping single fras
of pornography and the family films hey
rageous dog with the celebrity voices
meet for the first time in real three
that's when you'll catch a flash of
Tyler's contribution to the film of
course and the subsequent BuzzFeed
article never been a fight you no but
that that's a good thing no it is not
how much can you know about yourself you
never been in a fight oh wait what this
is crazy you want me to hit you that's
right mannerisms are great this is so
stupid
and
go
W hit me in the
ear I'm sorry ow Christ by the ear that
that looked that looked authentic oh
jeez oh my God how
awkward hit me
again this has got to be one of those
movies that has like accidental you know
like actual cont ATT I wonder if that
was one of
those
wow yeah damn
oh we should do this again sometime
homie is carrying himself carrying
himself different I don't know how Tyler
found that house but he said he'd been
there for a
year squatter's rights that's you that's
me that's toter toilet what a [__]
hole there were no Neighbors just some
warehouses and a paper mill that fart
smell of steam like in the building from
The Punisher
movie and they just always out here
tussling outside
l
oh oh can I be next damn drawing a crowd
we were finding out more and more that
we were not alone oh my my God have you
even been to your support groups it was
on the tip of everyone's tongue Tyler
and I just gave it a
name tom waights
[Music]
boy oh you got a space
now you got your little support group
meeting Hall Tyler gave the rules that
he and I
decided here come welcome to Fight Club
the first rule of Fight Club is oh you
do not talk about Fight Club there you
go second rule of Fight Club is you do
not talk about Fight Club third rule of
Fight Club someone yells stop goes limp
Taps out the fight is over okay safe
word that's good fourth rule only two
guys to a fight fifth rule one fight at
a time fellas so no itman you can't take
on like 10 dudes seventh rule fights
will go on as long as they have to
taking off your wedding ring and final
rule if this is your first night at
Fight Club you have to fight right you
have to fight of course this kid from
work couldn't remember whether you
ordered pens with blue ink or
black but Ricky was a God for 10 minutes
when he TR the major D of a local food
court God
Ricky sometimes all you could hear were
the flat hard packing sounds over the
yelling
yeah for the wet choke when someone
caught their breath and
sprayed ow but Fight Club only exists in
the hours between when Fight Club starts
and when Fight Club ends sure even if I
could tell someone they had a good fight
I wouldn't be talking to the same man
who you were in Fight Club is not who
you were in the rest of the world it's
like The
[Music]
Purge oh yeah buddy oh God is he just
wailing on his nuts I guess no rules
aside from the three
rules wow wow dude the way dudes used to
get buff in in this age is different
than it is now it's just that like lean
cut muscle feral animal
Instinct like at a Pentecostal
[Applause]
church people going to get
killed when the fight was over nothing
was solved but nothing mattered people
must die here here Fight Club became the
reason to cut your hair short or trim
your fingernails any historical figure
i' fight
Gandhi it's like Epic Rap Battles of
History hello where have you been the
last eight weeks yeah I haven't seen you
at any support groups yeah we split them
up yeah but you haven't been going to
yours how do you know cuz I've been I
cheated I found a new one really oh my
God only like the testicle
thing I'm just start saying that to
people I got a stomach full ofx I took
what was left of a bottle oh this isn't
a for Real's thing this is probably one
of those Cry for Help things golly do
you want to listen and see if my spirit
can use a
phone jeez dude you won't believe this
dream I had last night yeah I can hardly
believe anything about that last night
I'm going to have to go last night
Anonymous what what are you doing
here everyone in this movie is
feral you got some up friends I'm
telling you yep with friends like these
who needs anybody else I already knew
the story before he told it to
me oh you have heard of death rattle
before do you think you'll live up to it
name oh we'll find out I'm sure to
evacuate you a so oh now how could Tyler
of all people think it was a bad thing
that Mara singer was about to die uh I
don't know maybe he wants to get with
her yeah yep he
does oh somebody call the C Oh No 5
split
bro the
what
[Music]
the she's lost faith in herself the
singer let us help you she's a monster
you have every reason to live she's
infectious human weight oh my God I fall
asleep I'm done for yeah you're going to
have to keep me up all
[Laughter]
night what's your name your birthday
your address he was obviously able to
handle it you're not into are you uhoh
God not at all put a into my head and
paint the walls with my brains that's
good hey can't have you talking to her
about me why would I talk to say
anything about me or what goes on in
this house to her or to anybody okay I
mean who does he who does he have to
tell other than the fight club
guys
[Music]
wow I could have moved to another room
this house is going to collapse
but I
didn't oh there's some mood lighting for
you what
the what are you doing just going to
bed the kitchen gloves on who are you
talking to shut
up I became the calm little center of
the world I was the Zen master yep got
to soothe the Hulk within is that your
blood some of it yeah take the rest of
the day off come back Monday with some
clean clothes get yourself together oh
give up all your flaming worldly
possessions go live in a dilapidated
house in the toxic waste part of town
and you have to come home to this just
can't win man life is a
prison hello yes this is detective Stern
with the arson unit oh we have some new
information about the incident of your
former condo I don't know if you're
aware but it seems that someone sprayed
Freon into your front door lock then
tapped it with a chisel to shatter the
cylinder whoa dynamite dynamite left a
residue of ammonium oxal whoa do you
know what this means no what does it
mean chemistry it means it was
homemade you see whoever set this
homemade Dynamite could have blown out
your pilot light days before the actual
explosion who would go and do such a
thing I'll ask the question
yeah who who knows how to do such a
thing tell him you blew it all up that's
what he wants to
he are you saying that I'm a suspect no
no I may need to talk to you a little
further so how about you just let me
know if you're going to leave
town I love how much he doesn't sell it
like I love a a moment of acting where
the character is also acting I got this
dress at a thrift store for $1 it was
worth every penny all hundred of them
someone loved it intensely for one day a
then tossed it like a Christmas tree
jeez people love Christmas trees for
like a month you know what I really
think it's time you got out of here
don't worry I'm yeah not that we don't
love your little visit know you are such
a nutcase I can't even begin to
yes that's like a some kind of
impressionist painting right there what
are we doing tonight we make soap we
make soap to make soap first we render
fat oh where you going to get that
that's right we we we heard about his
soap business nowadays more than ever he
can have his own little cottage brand
selling bricks on the on the Instagram
come on Tyler the salt out has to be
just right so the best fat for making
soap comes from humans of course it
[Music]
does
oh
oh oh my God Jesus no no
no oh my
God once the towel hardens you skim off
a layer of Glycerin
Glycerine yeah with enough soap one
could blow up just about anything Tyler
was full of useful information yeah of
people's found their clothes got cleaner
when they washed them at a certain point
in the river you know why no the current
cuz human sacrifices were once made on
the Hills Above This Rim you knew that
was coming something like it this is lie
The crucial ingredient once it mixed
with the melted fat of the bodies a
thick white soapy discharge crept into
the river answer see your hand
please what is this this is a chemical
burn you will hurt more than you've ever
been burned and you will have a scar
whoo whoa whoa whoo without pain without
sacrifice we would have nothing fear is
the mind killer this is your pain this
is your burning hand it's right here I'm
going to my cave I'm going to my cave
I'm going to find my power animal no no
if our fathers bailed what does that
tell you about
God I have to consider the possibility
that God does not like you never wanted
you in all probability he hates
you we don't need him we don't damnation
man Redemption we are God's unwanted
children so be
it it's very Lucifer of you please let
me have please first you have to give up
first you have to know not fear know
that someday you're going to die oh you
don't know how this feels oh he
does yeah it's only after we've lost
everything that we're free to do
anything I guess
so
oh ow ow congratulations one step closer
to hitting
bottom I was at the bottom he was
wearing his yellow tie I didn't even
wear a tie to work anymore the first
rule of Fight Club is you don't talk
about Fight Club whoa what the who got
that make a managerial decision you find
this what would you do yeah I'd be very
careful because the person who wrote
that is dangerous and this button- down
Oxford cloth psycho might just snap and
then stalk from Office oh my God
ArmaLite AR10 carbine gas powered
semi-automatic weapon pumping round
after round into colleagues and
co-workers big man well maybe you just
shouldn't bring me every little piece of
trash you happen to pick up wow dude
damn compliance and liability my off
what what what are you talking about I
need you to check and see if there's a
lump in my breath that's nice
taking food to Mrs Han Mrs Reigns where
are they exactly tragically they're dead
I'm alive and I'm in poverty you want
any sure Meals on Wheels right there
feel anything no no nothing well that's
Rel uh could check your prostate I think
I'm
okay well thanks
[Music]
anyway D are we done
see you
around damn dude it's not very Alpha of
you bro it's not very enlightened and
detached from all this [__] bro
Cornelius
Cornelius uhoh it's me Bob Bob I got
something so much better now really what
is it well first rule is oh my God am I
supposed to talk about and the second
rule
is
I'm a member yeah I've never seen you
there I go Tuesdays and Thursdays I go
Saturday
congratulations damn have you heard
about the guy that invented this thing
well yeah actually I hear all kinds of
things yeah supposedly he was born in a
mental institution and he sleeps only 1
hour a
night he's the bastard son of a thousand
maniacs oh my God no come on
Bob bring the meat
[Music]
L bat out of hell this
[__] tapping
out get your testosterone back this was
mine and Tyler's gift oh my God our gift
to the world sure who are you m yeah who
Am I who are you I'm [__] L who the
are you
you don't own this place I do uh-oh
y'all are going to need a permit I want
everybody out of here right now hey you
should join our club did you hear what I
just said you and your
friend
yeah
yes I got it I got it [__]
I oh my
God Al we really like this place yeah
yeah that was so deed
oh hey oh my God Pat
jitz my
man shouts out to Pat
janitz
whoa
whoa please let us pleas please
chist I want your work I about your work
I'm my mother's Jesus Christ thanks
Lou you too big guy you
too this week each one of you has a
homework
assignment you're going to go out you're
going to start a fight with the total
stranger yes right there with the Flames
this is not as easy as it
sounds
whoa is that Bob in the lobby there whoa
dude normal people do just about
anything to avoid a fight this is a
priest what Courtyard like Atrium thing
is
that oh oh my God I wonder how they
knowing how David Fincher works I want I
want to know how they shot these fights
need to
talk this like bouncy anime music
where to begin with your constant
absenteeism with your unpresentable
appearance I am Jack's complete lack of
surprise you're the Department of
Transportation someone informs you that
this company installs front seat
mounting brackets that never pass
Collision tests and fuel injectors that
explode and burn people alive what then
are you threatening me no get the out of
here you're fire better solution you
keep me on the payroll as an outside
consultant and in exchange for my salary
my job will be never to tell people
these things that I know oh wow security
I am Jack's smirking
Revenge
a what are we doing here bud what the
hell are you
doing what the
[__]
what that hurt
sure oh my God no please it's like
watching like crazies or something for
some reason I thought my first fight
with
Tyler and my man over here is just like
giv the most you know
Vivid reaction faces just like just show
up and respond to all the crazy [__]
this dude
does this guy is going to be like like
completely traumatized by all of his
interactions with you now look give me
the paychecks like I asked and you won't
ever see me again and right then at our
most excellent moment
together telephone computer fax machine
52 weekly paychecks and 48 Airline
flight coupons this is how Tyler and I
were able to have Fight Club every night
of the week what Jesus Christ dude Tyler
was now involved in a class action
lawsuit with the prman hotel over the
urine content of their
sup of course of course he is Tyler is
an entrepreneur if nothing else Tyler
dreamed up new homework assignments he
handed them out and sealed envelopes
let's
go what
the going oh you destroying everyone's
TV satellite connections and all that
copies of alien on the show shelf Alien
[Music]
Fincher oh my god
dude they like magnetizing all the tapes
just inflicting their ideology on
everyone on Earth do you know there's a
Fight Club up in Delaware City yeah I
heard wow dude how many fight clubs were
born due to this movie and how many were
formed due to the book and what is the
crossover
[Music]
they got the accurate real uh Airline
pamphlets well done well done screaming
faces and everything stop for a second
hey what are we doing Turn Around what
are we doing homework assignment what
kind of homework assignment Human
Sacrifice oh yeah on a long enough
timeline the survival rate for everyone
drops to zero sure give me your wall
you're going to
die oh no an expired Community College
student ID what' your study
Rand stuff stuff stuff what did you want
to be Raymond
kle the question Raymond was what did
you want to be nope nope nope nope nope
animals animals stuff yeah I got that if
you're not on your way to becoming a
veterinarian in 6 weeks you will be dead
what the
[__] now there's some motivation for you
tomorrow will be the most beautiful day
Ry Chaos's life his breakfast will taste
better than any meal you and I have ever
tasted dude Tyler is jigsaw he had a
plan and it started to make sense in a
Tyler sort of way Tyler's jigsaw and I
like him
now I can definitely see why this movie
is so contentious you not your job
you're not how much money you have in
the bank not the car you drive you're
not the contents of your wallet or not
your awesome wardrobe that's new in
every scene
w I'll be out of your way in a sec you
don't have to go please don't go I need
you so my lovely you still going to
groups yeah nine days a week listen um
what what are you getting out of all
this
what is this making you happy is there a
happy to be made well sometimes I don't
know I don't understand I mean why why
does a weaker person need to latch on to
a strong person what what what is that
ug what do you get out of it no it's
it's not the same thing at all I mean
it's totally different with us survival
instincts what do you mean by us I'm
sorry do you hear to love triangle with
Tyler in the center you're not talking
about me are you no that day you came
over to my place play doctor what was
going on there what are you talking
about nothing nothing I don't think so
oh come on what do you want look at me
oh what's going on this conversation
this conversation is over is over I just
can't win with you can I
nope Too Young Aw give the man a chance
tomy's too young old too old fat too fat
applicant if the applicant then waits
for 3 days without food shelter or
encouragement he may then enter and
begin his training what you're too young
to train here end a story I quit wasting
our time get the out of here do you
think you're ever getting in this house
you're never getting in this you've got
to be aware of the ritual of this I
guess if
you're that R boy oh two pair of black
pants yes sir one pair of black boots
sir two pair of black socks sir $300
personal burial money yes sir personal
burial
money you're too old fat man a
[Music]
stick it out a he wants Bob to be
accepted there's a good guy deep down in
there that's got to be tough as an actor
I feel like an emotional moment uniquely
to shave your head on screen whoa ready
to sacrifice himself for the great
good understanding is cruel the monkey
said as he launched to space
and you you're too damaged blond and so
it went Tyler built himself an army we
are the all singing all dancing crap of
the
world you got a renovation crew out of
it you just want to stop living in the
heights of depravity Police Commissioner
Jacobs has just
arriv good catch Jesus Christ this is
one of many recent acts of analism
around the city somehow related to
underground boxing clubs oh my
commissioner Jacobs who just arrived on
the scene here of a four alarm fire that
broke out about an
hour wow dude did you guys do BL started
they did a terrorism sir the first rule
of project mayam is you do not ask
questions sir yeah you follow blindly
your bug eyed Overlord the victory in
the war against Crime will not come
overnight it will take dedication and
commitment End crime in our time this is
only the beginning I got to take a
piss this poor
guy oh jeez dude oh no oh
god oh no don't look too pleased with
yourself wowe
wowe
ah oo boy
[Music]
Jesu
christe why are you checking you're
going to publicly state that there is no
underground group or these guys are
going to take your ball
[Music]
ug oh lordy lordy lordy Lord
now it's a Christopher Nolan
movie I Am Jackson flame sense of
rejection
uh-oh it's Morin time boy Hulk out on
him smash
[Applause]
him o
o is is the mutton chops guy Dexter
Fletcher oh let went down jeez he go
kill him
oh
ah I felt like putting a bullet between
the eyes of every Panda that wouldn't
screw to save its species oh my goodness
gracious I wanted to breathe smoke oh my
God where'd you go psycho
boy I felt like destroying Something
Beautiful to hospital yeah who going to
pay for that
Airport parking
long you Mr
Jesus recycle your animals why wasn't I
told about Project Mayhem first rule of
Project Mayhem is you not ask question
Jesus Fight Club was the beginning now
it's moved out of the basement it's
called project mayh you and I started
fight club together Mischief Mayhem and
soap this does not belong to us we are
not special dad you you should have told
me you give all the orders dude what do
you want statement of purpose should I
email you should I put this on your
action item list yeah you need to forget
about what you know that's your problem
forget about what you think you know
about life about friendship and
especially about you and me
oh I don't love you
jack what are you
doing whoa guys what would you wish you
done before you die paint a
self-portrait build a house wow is is
that uh Hol mallan the guy from Guy from
M Hunter damn would you feel about your
life I don't know I wouldn't feel
anything good about my life is that what
you want to hear me say fine come on not
good wow
wow look at you pathetic why do you
think I blew up your condo oh yeah there
it is stop trying to control everything
and just let go let it go go let it go
punch it into a
[Music]
pulp now we done our seat
belts
wow
Jesus Christ I'd never been in a car
accident this must have been what all
those people felt like before I filed
them the statistics in my reports sure
you learn about a lot about yourself in
a car wreck as well as a fight in the
world I see you're stalking out through
the damn Canyon Forest around the ruins
of Rockefeller
sent feel better champ
they must have shot a whole bunch of
like horror stuff in this house and I
wonder if the interior is the same place
as the exterior
Tyler Tyler was gone
whoa was I asleep
organized wow Human Sacrifice wall the
house had become a living thing wet from
so many people sweating and
breathing so many people M the
house oh my God I had to hug the walls
trapped inside this Clockwork of Space
Monkeys cooking and working and sleeping
in
teams
wow Project Mayhem is
expanding it's under control sir wow I
father dumped me and they're still
making soap is that how you make money
aside from all his paychecks like can I
come in he's not here what no Tyler
isn't here I didn't come to see Tyler
Tyler's
gone bummer go to her man you know you
want to go to a support group for Old
Times start with AA got two gun
coming through who we were supposed to
kill two birds with one stone destroy a
piece of corporate
art and trash a franchise coffee
bar oh and you got to chase mamo's uh
sphere bomb from
fastex
wow the perfect Chain Reaction it went
smooth
until they shot
Bob ah ow they shot him in the head
[Music]
what okay quick we got to get rid of the
evidence we got to get rid of this body
bury him bury him Coral this is a person
he's a friend of mine and you're not
going to bury him in the guard he was
killed serving Project Mayhem sir sir
this is a man and he has a name and it's
Robert Paulson the voice actor from
Animaniacs in death a member of Project
M him has a name his name is Robert
Paulson oh my God his name is Robertson
come on guys his name is Robert this is
so strange you're going to will him back
to life his name is robt Robert pson his
name is Robert pson his name is Robert
[Music]
pson got to put on Tyler's shades that's
the key or eat some junk
food what Los Angeles Tyler D and Tyler
plain tickets I went to all the cities
on Ty ticket STS bar hopping I didn't
know how or why but I could look at 50
different bars and somehow I just knew
I'm looking for Tyler Duran I wish I
could help you uh-oh
sir uhoh I've seen some Tyler Duran's
Reddit post Cen him on Fortune Tyler had
been
busy setting up franchises all over the
country my God it's spreading like a
miasma like nobody knows what he looks
like he has facial reconstructive
surgery every 3 years what is it true
about Fight Club in Miami is Mr D
building an army fight club Miami must
be wild I was living in a state of
per everywhere I went I felt I'd already
been there it was like following an
invisible man Deja Vu I was always just
one step behind Tyler this looks like
one of the bars from The World's End
Welcome Back Sir how have you been wow
do you know me is this a test sir this
is not a test you were in here last
Thursday you were standing exactly where
you are now asking how good security is
it's tight as a drum
sir who do you think I am are you sure
this isn't a test no this is not a test
you Mr J that's that's that's what
somebody would say they're really trying
to prove a test
though is this is this about to be is is
oh wait a minute oh oh God Mar it's me
have we ever had sex this is a trick no
I need to know you want to know if I
think having sex or making love oh so
that's a yes just answer the question
Mara please did we do it I need to
verify my reality you're showing me a
sensitive side then you turn into total
[__] is that a pretty accurate
description of our relationship Tyler
whoa what did you just call me say my
name Tyler
Duran I'm coming over no wait Mara I'm
not there say name say my name you broke
your promise whoa oh [__] what the going
on here I ask you for one thing one
simple thing why do people think that
I'm you
ah answer me why do people think that
I'm
you I think you know
no I don't yes you do cuz it's one of
these you got it yeah no do
not
oh
dude it oh no because we're the same
person that's right we you're a
compartmentalize oh the shot I look like
you want to look I you want to I am
smart capable and most importantly
I'm free in all the ways that you are
not I'm a go-getter this is crazy people
do it every day they talk to themselves
they see themselves as they'd like to be
they don't have the courage you have to
just run with
it sometimes you're still you we should
do this again sometime other times you
yeah imagine yourself watching me if
this is your first night in Fight Club
yeah you're just like just down the hall
looking men you're just letting yourself
become Tyler
D no you have a house rented in your
name you have jobs you have a whole life
you have night jobs because you can't
sleep are you st make
soap uh technically Mara oh sure she
knows too much I think we're going to
have to talk about how this might
compromise our goals oh boy this is
[__] I'm not listening to this you
are insane no you're insane yeah it's
called a change over the movie goes on
and nobody in the audience has any idea
sure the cigarette
Burns I got to get out of
here I need you to initial this list of
phone calls
please oh jeers made it says right there
sir between 2: and 3:30 this
morning yep every night have I been
sleeping
later yeah has Tyler been taking over
for longer Deja all over
again yeah with enough soap one can blow
up just about anything oh wow oh that's
right the whole face off opening scene I
know that I've been acting very very
strange okay I I know that it's got to
seem like there's two sides to you and
you're watch two sides you're Dr Jackal
and Mr
Jack I care about you and I don't want
anything bad to happen to you because of
me huh your life is in
danger oh boy I've involved you in
something terrible that's about to
happen you are not not sayfe shut up
o you can't leave like you're
not
oh Empire's crumbling go over me I don't
ever want to see you again that's fine
if that's what it takes here wait I'll
be right here
[Music]
[Applause]
seven years some or other on the Marquee
take this money and get on this bus and
I promise you I will never bother you
again if that's what you want shut
[Music]
up you're the worst thing that ever
happened to me sure did he base Tyler on
the actor Brad Pit seven years of Tibet
is on the Marquee I need you to arrest
me I am the leader of a terrorist
organization respons responsible for
numerous acts of vandalism and assault
all over the city wow this is a tightly
regimented organization with many cells
capable of operating completely
independent of central leadership now go
to the house okay 1537 paper Street
that's our headquarters paper Street in
the basement you're going to find some
bathtubs that have been used very
recently to make large quantities of
nitroglycerin oh I believe the plan is
to blow up the headquarters of these
credit card companies and the TRW
building wow dude it's why credit card
company if you erase the debt record
then we all go back to zero yep I really
admire what you're doing oh no you're a
brave man to order this you're a genius
sir oh no you said if anyone ever
interferes with Project Mayhem even
you we got to get us balls
jeez big mistake fellas you said you'd
say that I'm not Tyler dirt you told us
you'd say that too oh my God all right I
am Tyler d l me I'm giving you a direct
over we are avoiding this mission right
now you said you would definitely say
that oh my god oh no out of your mind
your police
officer oh my God it lurks everywhere o
the blade on that thing I got him sir we
have to qu this stop fighting you're
going to [__] where's the rubber band R
away from me [__] KN gra
it get down on the
floor oh that guy's pants all the way
off he running out of the streets in his
underwear now how far the mighty have
fallen I ran until my muscles burned and
my veins pumped battery acid I run so
far
away run around you p man you look like
a crazy person to you coming from you
that means a
lot who
nice oh yep we're here at the base of it
all oh boy ain't nothing you can do
right there's got to be a million
contingency
plans
yeah I'm stopping this greatest thing
you've ever done man no no you know
there are 10 other bombs and 10 other
buildings God damn it since when's
project May him about murder the
buildings are empty security maintenance
all our people we're not killing anyone
man we're setting them free G wouldn't
do that not unless I knew which wise for
what if you know then I know hey it's
good or oh maybe I knew you'd know so I
spent the whole day thinking about the
wrong one
he the green one pull anyone but the
green
one this guy always I ask you not
do hug he out in the garage now punching
himself in the face get away from the
V the irony of Tyler he's always got the
like freshest drips and most opulent
getups
o oh here it
come
oh that's an interesting cut to the
security cam oh
oh
oh ow
Punk yeah God in the sound it's just
like the the dis Chorus at the begin of
2001 or something what okay how is that
all happening 3 minutes this is it the
beginning I think this is about where we
came in would you like to say a few
words to Mark the
occasion I'm sorry I still can't think
of
anything out these windows we will view
the collaps of financial history one
step closer to economic
equilibrium oh boy
ow is she here I'm begging you please
don't do this I'm not doing this we are
doing this this is what we want no this
is what we want you is meaningless now
we have to forget about you experience
ego death Jack you created me I didn't
create some loser Alter Ego to make
myself feel
better sure please call this off have I
ever let us down uh subjective I will
bring us through this as always I will
carry you kicking and screaming and in
the end you will and when you see one
set of footprints in the sand Tyler
Duran was carrying you the whole time
but this is too much I don't want this
what do you want want to go back [__]
job condo World watching sitcoms [__] me
I won't do
it this can't be happening maybe a
healthy balance is what it
requires I can figure this out I can
figure this out this is even real cing
in your
hand I can't in my hand yes you're
seeing the Matrix
now oh yeah you knew that oh he doesn't
even have to do it not my head
Tyler oh ours Yours Mine and
Ours where you going with this Ika
boy yeah where you going
fur
hey you and me
friends
Tyler My Eyes Are
Open oh my God what a
shot oh my
god oh and the smoke in his mouth that's
crazy whoa whoa are you all right sir
oh yeah I'm
okay sir what
happened no
problem sir he's not kidding you look
really awful you need medical assistance
you're like Jackie boy right now hi
Bara what kind of sick game are you
playing at putting me on a [__] oh my
God your face yes Mara look at me I'm
really okay how trust me
everything's going to be fine exact
[Music]
whoa what a needle very strange time in
my life you met me at a very strange
time in my
life
yeah that needle drop boy
wo
mine oh where is your m
this down in some deep dark hole
somewhere narrator they call him and
they and they even spliced
a fun little image in for us at the very
end wow
dude I'm going to need a minute to
process
this it's good though cuz like after so
many years of again having this movie
you know built up and its you know
status continuing to grow and shift as
Society continues to grow and shift like
you know this this
certainly was a substantial meal some
the chew on you know I would have been
fascinated to have experienced this at
the time in which it it you know was
originated but also from the Here and
Now
fascinating
experience uh I love this powder blue
text for the credits here why why don't
we take a second I'm going to I'm going
to just you know process this for a Hot
Mo and uh let's let's let's hear from
our video sponsors today completely INF
fitting with this motion
picture thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in Ecommerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify e-commerce
Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations shop makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales of scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
there are war-winning support always
there to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com reex all
overc case shopify.com reex start your
Shopify success story now let's grow
together with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real Game Changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what you
heard is true believe me this channel
knows you can use expressvpn to watch
movies and shows on Netflix that are not
available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over
a 100 countries like a global cinema at
your fingertips it's super easy open
Express VPN switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix
Hulu BBC I player YouTube or more
expressvpn has you cover and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com reex so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again oh my goodness
okay God man finally like this movie has
been looming over me since it came out
way back in the day I wasn't kidding
like this and blade I feel like came out
around the same time and were both
movies where like I saw the poster in
the you know newspaper section where
they had all the movies and I like would
cut it out and be like oh man I don't
know what this is uh but I want to see
it you know Mischief Mayhem and soap it
grabbed me good marketing and uh I can't
imagine what I would have gotten out of
this if I had watched it at the time of
release obviously I think I think I'm
kind of at least from my vantage point
here in this moment I feel like U I've
caught this at the right time in my life
because obviously I mean you know this
is a movie that's been hot hotly debated
over time and and certainly you know
whenever you see Memes online of like
the the quintessential if you idolize
this character you're missing the point
starter package figures you know you
often see Tyler Duran con included among
them and for good reason I mean this is
it's it's a fascinating sort of um Roar
Shack test I guess I would call it
because yeah this is uh it reminds me
certainly of um oh God what was the
other movie that came to mind just as we
American psychos certainly where like
there's a certain amount of people who
really kind of uh Buy in wholeheartedly
to the power fantasy that that movie
presents and the uh perspective of its
lead character and granted here you know
the lead character is you know a duel is
a split personality essentially um but
you know Jack and Tyler are cut of the
same cloth they're two sides of the same
mind uh and yeah it's it's the humanity
or what's what's left of the humanity
this like stunted uh kind of neutral
human presence in Jack being you know
sort of further and further corrupted by
you know this Persona he dreamed up to
you know realize what he sees as being
his full potential and the way in which
I I found it fascinating you know CU
this is one of those movies that has
that twist and I feel like it's hard it
joins a Pantheon or It joined a Pantheon
of you know movies that that have some
sort of yeah alternate personality Motif
uh either meant to you know shock us
with a Twist or I think here um more
directly just sort of comment like I
think there are two uses often of this
twist either it will be to get you know
a shock in on you and uh you know really
pull the rug out and and kind of try and
Dazzle you with cleverness or I think
you know this is an example of a movie
where like it is a surprise certainly it
is a Twist but I feel like it is more of
a thematic element and even though part
of the fun I would imagine would be
going back and rewatching the film and
sort of noting where and how Tyler
appears around other people and you know
what their interactions are like and you
know when you trade you know the
figurative you know visual
representation for who is really talking
in any given moment you know it's like
I'm sure you'll be switching out like
they like they acknowledge sometimes
Jack is like on the periphery just sort
of spectating and is sort of um you know
much further from the spotlight as he
just lets Tyler take control and and you
know and lets him grandstand and and
really soaks in just the full complete
Indulgence of being Tyler maybe with
with one toe still in reality then and
there are the times where yeah he's
blacking out and becoming entirely Tyler
and granted we don't really see a heck
of a lot of Tyler on his own but it is
fascinating too because um yeah like
just thinking back again like this is
one of those movies where you start to
talk about it you start to kind of think
about and break it down and especially
the way we shoot these you know here in
real time part of me is like oh man
there's going to be so much more that
probably would come from a second
examination or just further rumination
and whatnot um but yeah I thought this
made really interesting use of a motif
like that and yeah as a means of
commenting on you know the kind of uh
position that we meet this guy in or at
least the perspective that is extolled
through his narrations and his you know
sort of declining mental state as the
movie goes on this guy who you know it's
funny he what is it because because uh
American Psycho Brett Easton Ellis right
and then this is Chuck pic uh American
Psycho author yes okay yeah BR Stones so
like it's interesting that these should
come from a similar moment in time for
both literature and Cinema because like
these do feel very akin to one another
in a sense because you have this
protagonist who's living this yepy you
know uh you know uh catalog successful
kind of life where he's got the condo
and he's got all his furniture needs
taken care of and he spends time you
know meticulously orchestrating and
stressing over material things stuff
and his life has become this sort of
empty cycle of clocking into work where
he doesn't feel very autonomous or
empowered you know he feels obviously
the onwe that comes with being just a
cog in a repeating cycle in a society
that prioritizes productivity and
efficiency while also you know sort of
creating these wasteful Frameworks in
order to achieve that at least some of
the time certainly is illustrated by
moments in this movie like they're when
they're having that little meeting and
the guy takes a break to be like you
know efficiency is the top priority as
we go through the motions of this
presentation and so like it's a fun
thought experiment and I can see why
again much like an American Psycho or a
joker or something like that um how you
might have again it's easy to probably
look upon this and and have it what am I
trying to say it's like there's not as
clear of a
prescribed I guess message only in that
I would imagine that this is the kind of
work that especially kind of peers back
into the reader and I can certainly see
how some people would feel uh gravitated
toward and enticed by Tyler Duran's
whole philosophy and I can understand
the sort of again feeling of of anger
and sort of Rage with no direction or no
like proper outlet and um yeah just the
resentment and uh and I don't know the
the sort of Decay that can put on your
soul as you're sort of further and
further consumed by you know the the
[__] of modern living and you know
you don't feel very in control of or
very powerful in your circumstances
perhaps you know these are two guys who
are living in the illusion of that and
certainly American Psycho you know looks
at it more from the top whereas this is
looking it at it more from the bottom
you know it's like you have the the
white collar yepy guy in American Psycho
with that kind of specific onwe and
Detachment and disregard for human
Humanity in particular and then here you
know you're looking up as you know from
the perspective of the marginalized and
the Forgotten not in terms of maybe uh
you know there are various ways in which
you know you can find yourself in that
position this way is looking at it from
you know the sort of uh the middle class
Rat Race kind of perspective where it's
like yeah you're just one of a number of
faceless cogs in a big machine and it
doesn't really care about you and it
just incentivizes you to keep consuming
and to keep fretting about things that
don't really matter when meaningful
experience lies right outside and just
outside the track that Society sort of
prescribes to you and then you know you
basically watch as these characters
these people who gravitate toward the
fight club you know find their uh uh
means of sort of yeah stripping all that
away you know down to the bone sort of
orchestrating this weird hyper physical
ego death and like it's it's a
fascinating thing and I think that that
it it earns its contentious and also you
know uh well regarded place in you know
both Cinema and I'm sure literary
history in that yeah like there are a
lot of people who probably take the
wrong message from this and and who
probably do just idolize Tyler wholesale
um and It's tricky because it's like
certain of those
philosophies kind of make sense you know
it's like like at least some of the
baselines of again you know not being so
consumed by material items and and yeah
having a cookie cutter life because
that's what Society tells you to do if
you know you're missing out on you know
there's so many things that we yeah get
wrapped up in and that feel so important
and so you know sort of Life altering or
shaping or whatever it is so pertinent
and they really aren't and there are so
many things that feel like rules in
society that really aren't but this is
kind of taking the frustration that
comes with again that lack of control
and that lack of you know feeling that
you're unique and valuable and all that
stuff and it's taking it to like the
furthest possible opposite extent where
by the end they're making their own
faceless you know little uh uh you know
this militia of sorts but that is
basically all kind of trickling down
from the orders of one guy and this one
ideology and nobody has names everyone's
kind of faceless they all dress the same
and nobody asked questions and they're
all just sort of like 100% Allin on this
ideology and it's you know it's just an
equal opposite you know sort of
corrosive system that they create and
then you're watching as Jack you know is
sort of in the middle of all this being
pulled from yeah the Ani and the Mala
that come with the rat race of society
into this feral state of yeah like
squatting in this old building and
making soaps and learning how to
homemake bombs and and then you know
literally taking to the streets and and
committing acts of Terror and trying to
physically destroy these things that
keep us again complacent and distracted
by so many things that are unimportant
by comparison to you know the things in
life that really make us want to you
know live and reach our best potential
and so it's like you're watching all
this Mayhem again and uh this this you
know sort of wild unbridled
you know corrosive ID on display
basically it's just following like the
most Bas animal instincts the most it's
making a collective but out of like this
individualist uh kind of I I don't know
it's weird it's there's an interesting
sort of individual but then the group is
also an individual because of how
homogenized everything is and we are a
monolith you know nobody talks about
this thing outside of the moments in
which we uh you know meet up and and
that even too like there are lots of
great Clues throughout to the Tyler
twist I think just just again thinking
back on this first watch with like the
flickers where he shows up or or certain
Choice uh moments of dialogue that are
certainly going to elude me now but um
but yeah just like different ways in
which they uh uh kind of draw attention
to and and foreshadow The Twist I think
are kind of fun and interesting as well
as as in this moment I'm I'm reminded of
the line where he basically says like
you know the fight club this this thing
we do doesn't exist it only exists when
we meet up to do this and uh and yeah
just like little cheeky uh nods in the
dialogue like that and so then yeah
physically in that moment you know Jack
is in the center of the room addressing
everyone as Tyler while the Jack Persona
yeah sort of hangs in the periphery and
observes and it's interesting just to
see yeah the different positions and
proximities the personalities and habit
or even the way again just like when
they're at the house just Tyler is
always just kind of like bouncing around
in the back and he's always like
munching on stuff and he he's I wonder
if they even maybe had him appearing and
disappearing from places that wouldn't
entirely make sense like he does feel
like somebody who's just kind of walking
around all through the back of this
guy's mind uh you know
Jack and uh and yeah just like the way
this all starts out this is yeah
definitely a stylized movie the dialogue
and the pace all have a a real Rhythm
about them um and I like the way that Ed
Norton you know really brought this
permeating sense of Malay and Detachment
throughout um and I'm reminded of that
one scene where he's like you know lying
to the officer on the phone or feing
concern over his blown up apartment uh
as the guy's investigating and it's like
you're watching an actor give a
performance where a guy is acting over
the phone and you know it's always a fun
little metal layer where you're like you
know Jack is probably not you know the
actor that Ed Norton is so to watch
somebody do that layer of I'm in
character but this character is acting
it's always an interesting thing and I
think that's another sort of nice little
um just spiritually attuned uh little
detail here um and yeah just his
interplay off of Brad Pit and I do
wonder if that's like a an Easter egg
that actually kind of cements that
because Brad Pit certainly is cast for a
reason uh he I again at this time I feel
like his profile would have been pretty
high and he's still in the younger phase
of his career so he's like you know
super hot as is on display frequently
throughout this um and so I wonder if if
it is that thing where it's where it is
that Jack you know knows who Brad Pit is
and uh you know has seen some of his
movies and just chose this guy
subconsciously as you know the
embodiment of all the things that he
wish he could be his most Alpha and his
most masculine instincts and um yeah
again that's that's the kind of
interesting and conflicting thing about
this is that there are aspects of
Tyler's message that are enticing and
that do you know sort of call upon you
to yourself from yeah the shackles of
the mundane the stuff in your life
that's weighing you down because it's
not actually important and like that
scene where they hold the guy up at uh
the liquor store and he you know grills
him about like what'd you go to school
for you know uh Stuff n you be more
specific than that come on you know like
this is important this is a life and
death situation what did you go to
school for biology why biology stuff I
don't know I wanted to be a vet you know
like getting past all these layers you
know that that that we accumulate one
some of them are thrust on us some of
them we pick up in in different ways but
you know Society life in society
especially in modern society you know it
is a hard thing to find your footing in
especially if you are not you know in
the Upper Crust of it you know it could
be really hard to find purpose in life
and feel like you're in tune with like
the reason that you're act actually here
and you know yeah I think the
interesting thing and the thing that
makes this movie so heavily debatable is
the fact yeah on face value aspects of
Tyler's you know call and philosophy you
know do kind of uh uh ask that you yeah
free yourself in some ways you know
harshly maybe ripping a Band-Aid off to
kind of Free Yourself of you know so
many things that you've been saddled
with and and to create the sort of rush
of immediacy that forces you to make a
choice make a change make a growth of
some kind um but yeah it's just taken to
the most rotten extent because it's not
tempor by anything it becomes just this
festering destructive miasma where it is
you know seeking basically to inflict
this ideology on everyone and everything
to yeah reshape the world you know as we
you know this this angry marginalized
fuse sort of SE fit angry entitled
disaffected you know to to pull a
buzzword like it is the worst of all the
masculine instincts kind of Amalgamated
together and then INF icted upon the
world around because it's true it's like
it's interesting you know it's like yeah
I think it's true that you don't really
there are things you just don't ever
know about yourself until you're in a
fight or until you're in some kind of
intense maybe even life or death
situation and uh and there are ways to
deal with and sort of Broach that you
know that can be healthy or whatever or
at least can make you into a
well-rounded person and I feel like
that's the interesting thing here is
that like you know nobody's trying to
get to the point of well-roundedness
it's like an extreme reaction to an
extreme feeling that's begat by just a
bunch of little you know again mundane
factors building up and overlapping into
yeah a pile of what can often very much
feel like [__] and make people feel
invisible and alone but that but that
yeah you don't need to go destroying
everyone's World
literally to uh make change on or to
wake up from I mean it's up to the
individual to wake up from this any way
and not necessarily again to just
inflict this chaos and this theory wanly
on everybody and the further Society
goes and now we have a much more you
know sort of technologically inclined
Society than when this movie was made
but it's still there in the way they
reject TV and media and too the way you
have ads throughout this movie I was
curious and I bet it's a little bit of
both as to whether there was like
product placement intentionally just to
get budget or if it was also kind of
messaging that yeah these advertisements
and and this stuff this onslaught of
stuff is just omnipotent and ever
encroaching upon your reality um you
know there's just yeah there's a lot to
what Tyler Duran is getting at or at
least like the seed that grows this
gnarled tree that is Tyler Duran um you
know the waking up from you know the the
mundane Rat Race that chips away at your
soul and that just mutes your passion
and makes you feel you know castrated or
impotent or or or you know ailing and
various ways marginalized in various
ways you know breaking out of that and
and creating circumstances in which you
have to really just sort of be in the
moment here and now making a choice and
you know unlocking the potential of of
just the randomness of being a liot like
there are ways in which that message is
valid and there are healthy ways of
enacting it but part of the point is
that you're watching this philosophy
filtered through the most extreme
reaction to what is happening I mean
this guy snaps he blows up his by the
end we realize this guy snapped uh you
know blew up the apartment full of stuff
he'd spent so much time sculpting and
fussing over and then yeah completely
had a wholesale rejection of you know
the entire societal system and then by
the end realizes like oh God I got to
meet somewhere in the middle actually uh
you met me at a very strange time in my
life where I'm finally maybe starting to
learn that like yeah you do need to take
control of your life and there certain
people you do just need to tell off
there's certain things that you do need
to you know uh reject or refuse to stand
for or whatever it is however you can't
just go forcing this on everybody and
assuming that this one ideology is good
for everyone because that's kind of
what's Happening that's kind of what's
happening in the thing that you're
reacting to um so yeah and then you have
Mara on the other side who is like just
as much sort of left to languish you
know underneath the shadow of you know a
pretty uncaring and and constantly
cycling system and I mean their
relationship part of me was expecting
her not to be real by the end too just
because again like whenever she steps
out into traffic there's this just sort
of like un otherworldly thing where like
you know just like the cars gracefully
are always missing her and like whenever
Ed Norton steps out in the street it's
complete opposite just like chaos
immediately um but yeah her presence I
would be curious to go back and
reexamine because you know he he meets
this girl in his space and I mean there
are women in these support groups but I
think that there's something else
interesting in the fact that yeah he's
and and what a twisted hook to start off
with this guy who is you know
emotionally repressed and who feels
again just marginalized by the
circumstances of his life and and made
sort of voiceless and impotent and and
uh you know unimportant by all these
other concerns around him that he is
just sort of in the middle of
maintaining uh you know he finds
a means of you know unlocking his
vulnerability and his emotions but also
in like a weird experimental kind of
anthropological sociopathic kind of way
crashing uh these support groups
pretending to have these ailments
becoming territorial over them
gatekeeping them and then this girl
shows up who is this is in the same form
as it's like there are other women in
the support groups and stuff but you
don't really ever They Don't Really Ever
break out of the ensembles of those
moments whereas like Mara you know is
you know kind of the equal you know
female counterpart in certain ways to
Jack except a little less unhinged uh
you know from a different life
experience different perspective Etc and
like watching them work out who gets
which support groups when and all that
stuff and just yeah that idea that this
guy is like unlocking his ability to
like feel these these Unbroken swells of
emotion that have probably been building
up and festering for so long only to
then swing back in the opposite
direction like it's an interesting sort
of uh uh exploration of yeah of coming
of age when your growth is sort of
stunted by a lot of the things that can
stunt growth in society it's easy to
grow up into a 30-year-old boy or child
or whatever he says there so yeah coming
to this place where it's like he gets
these extreme emotional outbursts and
outpourings you know through these you
know intimate interactions with these uh
these survivors or these people who are
coping with various ailments people who
actually have real Pro that's the thing
is is I think it doesn't help to be like
these people have real problems and the
character of Jack doesn't it's like
their problems are are much more grim
and existential in a sense certainly uh
and you know it doesn't always it
doesn't pay to start comparing you know
problems but yeah it's like if you're
looking at it from the outside you're
like this guy who does doesn't have any
sort of like real lifethreatening
problem at the moment other than yeah
the sort of oppressive malays that can
set on when you're living in capitalist
Society uh yeah it's like he's this
grifting sort of Cipher that comes in
and and that genuinely seems to I guess
maybe want to feel something but also
doesn't understand enough to process all
of those emotions and then yeah instead
of you know I guess the the reason that
doesn't fully work is because it's it
still doesn't fix the you know sort of
sense of Rage from within and the and
the Longing To like take some kind of
meaningful action to catch everyone's
attention and change everything and I
think there's also just the idea that
you know nihilistic destruction only
leads to and beg gets more nihilistic
destruction and so by the end of the
movie I almost feel like yeah it's like
he went to one extreme you know just
sort of trying to understand emotion the
most extreme way possible in order to
get that catharsis then going switching
over to the most physical catharsis
tearing down my soul first then tearing
down my body and the world around me and
then finally resting at the end in a
sort of middle place of like you know
what maybe instead of like trying to
divide everything up and and keep you
know here's your stuff Mara and here's
my stuff over here you know instead I
think we can kind of look at the world
around and realize that we're both
caught up in this and there's probably
not a lot we can do to completely
control and change it because we are
just two small figures in a crumbling
you know Skyline here however um you
know maybe something in between these
two instincts can lead us forward and
maybe together we can do that instead of
again homogenizing and tearing down and
destroying and again just you know kind
of devolving into aoral anarchic chaos
cuz yeah like there are ways in which
you know we have been separated from the
natural world and our animal instincts
and our you know sort of traditional
roles as hunter gatherers and and things
like that um however you know uh there's
a way to embody those things without
just perpetuating want and toxic
destruction which is you know sort of
the furthest extent that this ideology
this fight club grows into is just like
the unchecked you know ID the unchecked
desire to just you know destroy rebuild
and Destroy again and probably not even
rebuild that you know sturdily in the
first place and then yeah sort of waking
up to the idea uh when it's maybe too
late you know that uh that yeah maybe
this
ideology is a bit problematic a bit
toxic and once you let that cat out of
the bag and once that you know spreads
to enough people you might not be able
to contain it again and then you might
have some real problems on your hands as
are demonstrated by the fact that he's
like running around being like oh my god
what have I done what have I created
just this this this one you know sort of
snap has you know spread so far beyond
me and to all these other people and uh
and is creating yeah this sort of
dystopic you know terrorist threat now
which you know as time moves forward and
it's like we've seen it in movies like
The Batman as well with the Riddler and
the way you know that is pulling
obviously from radicalization that has
happened online that's been spurred on
by you know movies and and stories and
ideologies similar to this you know and
certainly inspired by this you know it's
it's a fascinating uh again piece of
social satire and I guess that's always
the risk of satire as well is that it it
always will run the risk of being
misinterpreted as something you know
genuine by people who simply share the
ideology that is being sa tired uh so I
mean yeah it's it's it's always
fascinating to watch a movie or a piece
like this because you just feel the way
in which again what it's communicating
and and the ideas it's exploring are
very much sort of relevant and alive and
and permeate our current moment perhaps
even more than they did you know or at
least in a more visible way than they
did when this was released originally I
can see why a lot of people latch on to
this probably who do you know kind of
feel like they're owed something and are
angry and who want to yeah tear down the
complacent society that doesn't care
about you and that feeds you all this
meaningless nonsense and expects you to
just keep the psycho humming while a
couple people at the top really live The
Good Life while the rest of us are down
here aspiring like there's a lot of
legitimate anger that permeates this and
yeah just like the most toxic extent of
all the most masculine instincts of
counteracting it and so yeah it's like
Mara is a total mess too and is a junkie
and various other things and is you
again living in complete poverty but has
like a totally different sort of means
of flitting through these scenes and
scenarios and so like her Mania and the
Tyler Duran Mania are like very
different but they do pose these
interesting sort of complimentary
yinyang is influences on uh Jack you
know as his his little table here uh
yeah I don't know like there's I'm sure
there's plenty that's already been said
about this movie and I feel like I'm
rambling a bit just because it is such a
a piece and it is uh pretty rich with
you know both style and themes I mean
David Fincher obviously is well known
for having an intense you know sort of
uh eye for exactly what he wants and and
for exactly how he wants his movie paced
out and composed and what the Rhythm
should be and yeah I mean this was wild
um and irreverent and and and it
certainly had a a past to it but it
wasn't like yeah some kind of like you
know CRA it wasn't like watching like a
guy Richie movie where it's like every
moment is like Zip Zip Zip but it does
constantly have this percolating music
and this really stylized dialogue but
that isn't too wacky you know and uh and
yeah just like some really fascinating
and interesting cinematic choices and
two with David finer I mean certainly
when to use CG and and certainly there
are like there's that one love making
scene there's the kitchen exploding and
stuff like that uh uh the bomb wires
things that you know use CG in ways that
you would probably need it for you know
to do what he wants to do but it is
interesting because we think of these
guys and and there's been talk lately of
you know like oh no CG and whatever the
killer or whatever um but you know and
even in Panic Room I remember seeing a
featurette about like how they cged
completely one of the sequences or
something like that and you can tell
more now but I think it is interesting
just to see those moments in a movie
like this uh because again you two you
have like so many people who have shown
up in comic book movies and big
Blockbusters and stuff so to see these
like totally CG sequences but that are
for completely different purposes than
they would normally nowadays be used in
uh it's just sort of fun and interesting
and uh and yeah like the whole concept
of the fight club itself and just all
the people that it attracts and all
these again different guys who are
yearning in some way shape or form to
feel powerful or to at least feel in
control and and yeah the Euphoria and
freedom it is fascinating it is a an
unruly and a multifaceted piece for sure
and I'm definitely going to be thinking
about it just more and more I'm excited
to hear more discussion now that I
actually have the full picture in mind
and and can sort of jump into the
nitty-gritty details because again you
know this movie famously carries with it
uh this sort of uh just
this mantle of being a problematic fave
for a lot of people and I could
absolutely see how you would watch this
from one perspective versus another I
found this to be very Darkly funny and I
can imagine a lot of people maybe not
not finding it so much or finding
different aspects Darkly funny and it
all depends on again where your Humanity
lies and and how you you know process
things like marginalization and rage and
uh and just the friction that comes with
living in the system in general but yeah
I thought this was a pretty effective
piece of sort of Darkly comedic social
satire and film stylings obviously again
great soundtrack uh really well composed
by David Fincher and again like this is
a pulpy movie uh I I've you know we
watched zodiac recently like I'm used to
the more restrained fure and this one
while it's not like a horror movie or
anything like there are some real harsh
moments of violence and Gore and stuff
like that and uh and yeah I think the
cast all does a really nice job you got
Jared Leto before he was Jared Leto uh
meatloaf in here and of course Brad Pit
and Edward Norton are are you know great
as the center of the movie Helena bottom
Carter too seeing her in a role very
befitting of of kind of what I associate
with a lot of the characters she plays
but in a mode that's a little bit before
you know her Peak like Blockbuster
version of that with Harry Potter and
things like that um so yeah like this is
so much to sum up uh but I'm really glad
that I finally seen it it it it is and
isn't what I was expecting in a lot of
ways and uh and yeah like I can see the
treachery of this movie as a power
fantasy but I can also see the the
potency and the salience as a cautionary
tale and and uh yeah I'm curious to hear
your guys thoughts on it so uh let me
know what your thinking on Fight Club is
it one of your favorite movies uh you
know do you hate this movie what's your
take on it uh yeah hit me up in the
comments and we'll see you on the next
one much love for now and as always
cheers